breaking tonight police investigating
three homicides in north las vegas right
now all happening just hours apart thank
you for joining us tonight at 11 i'm
brian loftis now the most recent
homicide took place near civic center in
cheyenne less than a mile away from
another scene orco mana live there now
joining us with the very latest on these
active investigations orco
brian all three homicides that happened
here in north las vegas for deadly
shootings and the most recent two have
pretty similar circumstances now we are
here off of mary d avenue which is
cheyenne and civic center where police
are investigating the most recent
homicide you can see the crime scene
tape and several patrol vehicles in the
area police officers say that they were
sent to the scene around nine tonight to
investigate someone suffering from an
apparent gunshot wound that person only
described as a male died at the scene
and detectives and the csi unit are on
scene trying to figure out what happened
but the investigation is still in the
preliminary stages and then about an
hour earlier at 7 55 tonight officers
were sent to a very similar homicide
which happened on civic center just
north of cheyenne that's only a few
minutes away from the location of this
most recent homicide at the first scene
police found a male suffering from an
apparent gunshot wound he was taken to
the hospital but then died and then
there was also a third homicide that
happened earlier at 7 38 police say that
the subject which was a male adult was
pronounced dead on the scene and further
investigation revealed that he also had
suffered from an apparent gunshot wound
and police are asking anyone with any
information to call them at 702
and again the investigations into all
three of tonight's homicides are in the
early stages so stay with us both on air
and online for the latest developments
for now reporting live in north las
vegas work omana 8 news now